MATT WERNER: Hello.
Welcome to this authors
at Google
presentation this afternoon.
Thank you for joining us.
We have the pleasure to be
joined by Adam Mansbach and T
Cooper today.
Adam Mansbach is author of
Shackling Water, Angry Black
White Boy, The End of the Jews,
which was winner of the
California Book Award, and most
recently, Rage Is Back.
His book, The Dead Run, is
forthcoming in 2013.
He is best known for his
children's book for adults
titled Go the Fuck to Sleep.
It reached number one on
Amazon's best seller list a
month before its release,
and was a national
best seller in 2011.
The book is perhaps best known
by its audio version read by
Samuel L Jackson, which
went viral.
Mansbach lives in Berkeley,
California, and co-hosts a
weekly radio show called
Father Figures on KPFA.
T Cooper is an American
novelist.
He is the author of three
novels, Sum of the Parts,
Lipshitz Six, or Two Angry
Blondes, The Beaufort Diaries.
Cooper is also co-editor, with
our second reader, of the
anthology, A Fictional History
of the United States With Huge
Chunks Missing.
His writing has appeared in The
New Yorker, the New York
Times, The Believer, and
Poets And Writers.
His latest book that he's here
to talk about is Real Man
Adventures, just published
by McSweeney's.
And also, for the Googlers in
the audience, you may purchase
the books at discounted price
over in the back from Books,
Inc.
So without further ado, I'd like
to welcome T Cooper and
Adam Mansbach.
T COOPER: Hey.
Thank you so much for
the introduction.
Thanks for having us here.
My name's T Cooper, and I'm a
little confused because of all
the Google things I've been
seeing, and a little off my
game, because it's quite a
wonder here, as you all know.
To you, it's normal.
To me, it's mind blowing.
But I'm going to actually
start off with--
I think my wedding photos are
going to pop up because of the
screen saver, so let's get this
film part out of the way
as quickly as possible.
This is just a brief
intro to my book.
I guess I'm a multimedia kind
of author, although I don't
really call myself that.
But you'll see today
that you're
going to see some medias.
This is a short film adaptation
of a few sentences
from my book, and we'll
start off after that.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
What's the first thing people
ask when a woman is going to
have a baby?
Is it a boy or a girl?
We told the doctor
not to tell us.
We wanted to be surprised!
Well, I'm here to tell you
that gender surprises can
happen anytime.
Just ask my parents.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
T COOPER: OK, so that was a
very exciting multimedia
presentation for you all.
Is it OK if I just shut that?
Good?
OK.
So, I--
maybe you can tell
from the video--
am transgender, which is not
my favorite topic to talk
about, which is why I wrote
a whole book about it.
I've been actually touring
a lot of the book, and--
is the feedback coming because
I'm close to the line?
It's fine.
OK.
I've been touring a ton with the
book, and this is actually
kind of toward the
end of my tour.
And it is actually a very
strange place I find myself
in, because it's a topic that,
walking down the street,
buying shit at the grocery
store, picking up my kids at
school, like, I don't
deal with it.
I don't talk about it.
Many of my neighbors
don't know.
What would you know, except you
can tell I'm short, but
that's about it.
So, that said, I might seem a
little chippy about it, and I
apologize for that in advance.
But one way that I've been
dealing with my issues is by
having super guest stars
read with me on tour.
A couple weeks ago, we
had Clay Aiken--
you might know him as being a
second place runner up in
American Idol and on Celebrity
Apprentice, though I think he
probably should have won.
But he read with me,
and sang a song.
And I've some other guest
stars, like in LA, like
actors, guys from Curb Your
Enthusiasm, Arrested
Development.
And today, I have the Go The
Fuck To Sleep guy with me, to
be my personal little you know
what to read with me.
So I'm going to actually bring
him up, because this book is
kind of a conversation, I would
say, about masculinity.
By no means, we don't
call it a memoir.
It's not a memoir.
Hey, it's the Go The
Fuck To Sleep guy.
ADAM MANSBACH: Hey.
T COOPER: Sorry.
We go way back, and I just--
ADAM MANSBACH: Yeah, you knew
me before I was the Go The
Fuck To Sleep guy.
Hopefully you'll know me
after I'm the Go The
Fuck To Sleep guy.
T COOPER: I hope I get to.
ADAM MANSBACH: I hope
that happens.
T COOPER: Anyway, the book is
kind of a meditation on
masculinity, and it deals with
a lot of different genres.
And there's essay, there's a
little bit of memoir, but
there's a lot of conversations
and interviews.
So Adam is going to help me
read a chapter for you.
We're going to start with
the Passport chapter.
This is a chapter called Why
They're Called Passports, as
in pass ports.
And it's actually a actual
conversation that I had with
the United States Department of
State on the phone, when I
applied for my new passport
to have the proper
gender marker on it.
And it was returned to me.
And you're going to hear what
happened, I'm gonna say three
seconds after I got my passport
back in the mail, and
I was on the phone to the
Department of State.
So Adam is going to play the
part of the Department of
State, and I'm going to
play the part of me.
So you'll know when
I talk, I'm me.
And when he talks--
we're not going to
keep saying, me,
Department of State.
ADAM MANSBACH: Department
of State.
It's the role I was
born to play.
T COOPER: Yeah, no,
this is you.
All right, so I think
we're ready to go.
Are you--
ADAM MANSBACH: I'm ready.
T COOPER: OK.
He's been practicing
all night.
Me.
It's the last time
I'm saying it.
I don't understand what
the problem is.
You have my fee, you have
my correctly filled out
application, and you have a
letter from a surgeon saying
that I had sexual reassignment
surgery and have lived as a
man for several years.
ADAM MANSBACH: It doesn't say
you had complete sexual
reassignment surgery.
T COOPER: I see.
Well, what does complete sexual
reassignment surgery entail?
ADAM MANSBACH: It requires,
um, it requires
full complete surgery.
T COOPER: What is full
complete surgery?
ADAM MANSBACH: What you are
calling bottom surgery.
T COOPER: Well, so essentially,
in order to have
a passport that I can safely
travel with, I need to
disclose what's in my pants.
ADAM MANSBACH: I suppose you
could put it that way.
T COOPER: So I could have a
penis and giant boobs, but
you'd still let me have the M?
ADAM MANSBACH: I didn't make
up the rules, sir.
I'm just telling you
what it says.
T COOPER: Did you have to tell
the government what's in your
pants in order to get
your passport?
ADAM MANSBACH: Uh, sir,
I did not have to, no.
T COOPER: So does it seem fair
that I would have to?
ADAM MANSBACH: I can't
speak to that.
T COOPER: So you're
telling me--
ADAM MANSBACH: I'm sorry.
I just need evidence of complete
sexual reassignment
surgery, and then I can process
your application.
T COOPER: The doctor says he
considers it full sexual
reassignment surgery.
ADAM MANSBACH: It needs
to say complete.
T COOPER: OK, so you're telling
me I need to go to,
like, Zagreb, Croatia, and spend
like $50,000 on a far
from perfect procedure that
would give me, essentially, a
limp piece of sirloin hanging
between my legs for you to
issue me a passport
with an M on it.
ADAM MANSBACH: Again, sir, I
didn't make up the policy.
I just need something that
says you've had complete
sexual reassignment surgery.
T COOPER: I have completed
my transition.
ADAM MANSBACH: Not according
to the guidelines.
T COOPER: Whose guidelines?
ADAM MANSBACH: The Department
of State's.
T COOPER: What about
my guidelines?
Like, what if I'm OK
with how I am?
Actually, how about this?
Why don't you just tell me how
many inches of penis the
government requires to
decide that I'm male.
ADAM MANSBACH: I'm sure
I don't know, sir.
T COOPER: No, seriously,
how long?
Because I might just make
it in under the wire.
ADAM MANSBACH: I don't know.
T COOPER: OK then.
What if I don't have either?
Like, what if you can't tell?
What do those people get?
ADAM MANSBACH: Uh--
T COOPER: Or, what if I don't
want to discuss with a
complete stranger or put down on
record with the government
what I have down there, because
it's nobody's business
except mine and whoever
I share it with?
ADAM MANSBACH: Uh--
T COOPER: OK, this is just
extremely personal, and I'm
uncomfortable having to talk
about this with you just to be
able to travel freely and
comfortably in the world.
ADAM MANSBACH: I can assure
you it's not entirely
comfortable for me, either.
T COOPER: I know you're trying
to help, but can I just ask
you one more question?
ADAM MANSBACH: Yes.
T COOPER: All those guys in Iraq
getting their genitals
blown off by IEDs--
do you make them change their
passports from M to F when
they come home, because they
don't have penises anymore?
ADAM MANSBACH: I don't know
what you want me to say.
Send me a letter that says
you've had complete gender
reassignment surgery, and I'll
process your application.
T COOPER: Thank you, Mr.
Go The Fuck To Sleep.
We're stopping there.
OK.
So, my publisher is McSweeney's,
which is kind of
a playful, somewhat local
publisher, and they do a lot
of fun stuff with their books.
Like, mine comes
packaged in a--
you'll see if you
check them out--
like an old-timey pulp blacked
out magazine cover, where you
just see the title and
a big angry shark
face peeking through.
Another thing I got to do was
produce a CD with mostly
original music, all inspired
by various
chapters in the book.
So we have some really amazing
artists on there, like
Kathleen Hanna is a new band,
has a song on there.
A band called Hem,
which is great.
Rick Moody, the author, has
an original song on here.
And it's pretty cool, because I
sent them various chapters,
and because I wanted this to be
kind of a discussion about
masculinity, and not my being
the authority, because--
I mean, I am, but--
I felt like it was important
to have a lot of different
voices weighing in on
the conversation.
So not only are there voices in
the book like the one you
just heard--
the Department of State's--
but there's actually
musical voices.
So it's kind of cool to check
out a chapter and listen to a
song, as nerdy as that sounds.
And today, actually, I
might have a trivia
question, if we have time.
So it might be reality
TV based.
So brush up on that, and you
might get a free CD out of it.
But these are highly
collectible.
We only made like
1,500 of them.
And if you get a book today,
I think we have 10.
So the first 10 people who buy
books, you can walk away with
these as well.
Anyway, three of the songs in
here are kind of interstitial,
like interludes.
And they go along with six word
memoirs that I've written
for the book.
So what I'm going to do is read
you the six word memoirs,
and then play you the songs
that were written
based on the memoirs.
And they're actually by this
amazing artist named Peg
Hambright, who was a part of
the band, The Judy Bats,
which, if you're under 40, you
don't know who they are.
Thank god, you know them?
Bless you.
That guy knows The Judy Bats.
Early '90s.
Who cares?
OK, so I'm going to read for
you just these short clips,
and play the songs that
go along with.
OK, the first one
is called High
School, A Six Word Memoir.
Had a good personality,
I'm told.
[MUSIC - PEG HAMBRIGHT,
"INTERLUDE: HIGH SCHOOL"]
College, A Six Word Memoir.
Guys dug me.
I mostly declined.
[MUSIC - PEG HAMBRIGHT,
"INTERLUDE: COLLEGE"]
And My 20s, a six word memoir.
Thank god for Astor
Place Barber Shop.
[MUSIC - PEG HAMBRIGHT,
"INTERLUDE: MY 20S."]
Thank you to the Judy Bats.
All right, so I guess we need
to get this show rolling.
There are some heartfelt
things in the book.
There's a couple interviews with
my wife, who has to put
up with me.
There's a little bit about my
kids, who I don't talk a ton
about, but as you can imagine,
I have kind of a unique path
through this world.
I had one event in LA last
week where a celebrity
designer came up and told me,
after an actor read the part
of my wife and I read the part
of myself from the book, and
he said that our love was--
well, first he said I had an
aura radiating from me that
was, I think, red and very
healthy, and very vibrant, and
that I have great energy.
How are you doing?
What are you having for lunch?
She's not sharing.
So he was saying, as I was
telling my truth, which made
me want to die.
But then he said that my wife's
and my relationship
reminded him of LeAnn Rimes and
Eddie Cibrian, if anyone's
familiar with them.
He had another lady pregnant,
and then he left her and went
with this other lady,
Leann Rimes--
she's a country singer.
So I felt really honored and
blessed by that comparison.
I'm just trying to say there's a
lot of really touching stuff
in here that inspires a lot of
comparisons to true love.
I think we're going to read one
more thing, so we can get
the Go The Fuck To Sleep
guy out here again.
We're going to end with--
I didn't check to see if
it's OK to curse a lot.
Is that cool?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
T COOPER: OK, because this guy's
going to curse a lot.
Usually I clear the room of
children for this one.
It's not that bad, but,
you know, some
people are so sensitive.
But I'm going to read just one
more little bit of the book
for you guys, and then head out,
and we can do some Q and
A afterwards.
But I do want to encourage you
to, if you're interested at
all in the subject matter--
it's a very universal story,
like, the way I kind of go
through this is--
I don't know.
I feel like it's about--
all stories that are interesting
are about people
becoming who they're
meant to be.
So there is some heartfelt
stuff, despite what you're
hearing here today.
This is a chapter
called Dialogue.
I'm going to bring
him back up.
Adam, come join me.
Page 239.
So this comes later in the book,
and I've heard this is a
controversial part of the book,
but I'm going to do it
for you here today, because I
think you guys can take it.
I think you need a CD for
knowing the Judy Bats.
Are you interested in that?
OK.
Will you give this to him,
so I don't give feedback?
The rest of you are going
to have to buy
discounted books for that.
OK.
So what he's going to read for
you is an open letter to Brad
Pitt and Angelina Jolie, and
it's written by Bonnie Fuller,
and she's the editor of the
website Hollywood Life, Your
Celebrity News Gossip and Style
BFF, which means best
friend forever.
She used to be the editor
of Us Magazine is my
understanding--
that print magazine that,
well, no one cares about
print, but you might
have heard of it.
So Adam is going to read for you
Miss Fuller's open letter
to Brad and Angelina, exactly
as it appeared on her blog.
Take it away.
ADAM MANSBACH: I'm honored that
you would think of me for
the role of Bonnie Fuller.
T COOPER: Does anyone
have a wig?
ADAM MANSBACH: Can I ask you
one-- how do you pronounce
that word right there?
T COOPER: He doesn't
know Brangelina.
Everyone knows Brangelina.
ADAM MANSBACH: I thought
it was a hard G, maybe.
I'm not up on a lot of this
celebrity gossip shit.
T COOPER: It's like if we were
dating, we'd be like, Tadam.
ADAM MANSBACH: Wow.
T COOPER: Or Coopback.
ADAM MANSBACH: That's
yet another reason
we shouldn't date.
T COOPER: Done.
ADAM MANSBACH: Brangelina, what
are you doing to poor
Shiloh Jolie Pitt?
Your 3 and 1/2 year old daughter
is getting dressed in
boy's clothes so often by you
that the New York Post even
described her today
as your son.
And no wonder.
She was photographed in daddy
Brad Pitt's arms, heading into
the Broadway show Mary
Poppins on January
3rd, wearing a boys'--
literally--
Burton's--
this is terribly written--
Burton ski cap and black
puffy jacket.
In recent photos, she's been
decked out in a fedora, tie,
camouflage pants, boy vest,
pirate sword, navy knit skull
and crossbones hat, black jeans,
grey jackets, black and
white skull socks
and sneakers.
Even the stuffed animal
she carries is blue.
Never, ever is Shiloh
dolled up in
anything remotely girlish.
Her blonde hair is hidden under
hats or left unbrushed
and pulled to the side
of her face.
Her sister, Zahara Jolie Pitt,
however, is allowed to have
her girly touches.
Her Mary Poppins hair was pulled
into a blue barrette
and pretty bracelets.
Bracelets?
Sic.
Sic, yeah, bracelets.
Escaped from under the
arm of her coat.
And you're not dressing your
little boys like girls.
So Brad, and so Angelina,
what's up with the cross
gender dressing for Shiloh?
Did you both want another
boy, not a girl?
Maddox and Pax--
really, Maddox?
Weren't enough?
Aren't you worried that
you're going to
confuse little Shiloh?
Give her gender identity
issues?
Isn't it hard enough to grow
up without your parents
dressing you like the
opposite sex?
Motherfuckers?
I-- sorry.
I got carried away there.
I added that.
That was me.
A shrink says yes.
Angelina has said that she
was bisexual in public.
This is her bisexuality
coming through.
She's saying, I'm not going to
teach my daughter gender.
Let her pick, believes
psychologist Dr. David
[INAUDIBLE].
But will it confuse her?
Yes, says Doctor [INAUDIBLE].
She is being guided into
a bisexual role.
Her mother is projecting this
onto this particular child.
She has chosen her
as her favorite.
I think this is an issue.
Such an issue that Shiloh is
already insisting she be
called by a boy's name, John.
Not much imagination
on Shiloh, huh?
Brad apparently told Oprah that
Shiloh insists on being
called John, he explained.
It's a Peter Pan thing.
Peter Pan thing my-- ahem.
I just threw up a little
bit in my mouth.
Brad!
Does Shiloh even know what
the color pink is?
Has she even seen it?
Why do you let little Shiloh
be dressed this way?
All I can say is that Brad must
be whipped if he allows
this, believes Dr.
[INAUDIBLE].
Wow, Brad!
You're whipped!
Now, come on.
Time to get up your gumption for
the sake of your daughter,
and let her be a girl
if she wants to be.
Sincerely, Bonnie Fuller.
T COOPER: Thank you.
That was gorgeous.
That was beautiful.
ADAM MANSBACH: Thanks.
T COOPER: Truly beautiful.
Interestingly, there
was a response to
the letter that ran.
It's an open letter to Bonnie
Fuller from Shiloh Jolie Pitt.
And if you do check
out the book--
I haven't mentioned
that, have I?
If you do check out the book,
you'll see it's actually in a
child's writing, and I'm going
to read it for you here to end
this little party.
Dear Mrs. Fuller, wow are
you a stupid cunt.
I'm not the favorite.
Zahara is, duh.
And Maddox is the favorite
boy, by a landslide.
Everybody knows that.
It's an open secret
in our family.
And what's this doctor
you asked about
my mom sexual history?
Is he even a doctor?
I'm three, and I know that what
clothes somebody wears
doesn't make them attracted
to the same sex.
That's retarded.
Not to mention, I don't
even know what sex is.
And whatever it is, I won't be
having it for about 13 to 15
years anyway.
Stop sexualizing me.
It's creepy, like when those
ladies make their kids do
strip tease on Toddlers
and Tiaras.
Listen, lady.
I'm not the one who's
confused.
Society is confused.
Psych 101, gender is a socially
constructed concept.
Practically everything in
society is assigned a gender,
like toys, colors, behaviors,
my Burton ski cap, and
apparently, even simple black
jeans and a grey jacket.
My dad may be whipped,
but you spend all
day every day blogging.
Sincerely, John Jolie Pitt.
Thank you.
Thank you, Adam.
We're going to bring him
up, and take it away.
ADAM MANSBACH: Hey, what's
going on, guys?
How's everybody feeling?
AUDIENCE: Good.
ADAM MANSBACH: All right.
All right.
So, I have a couple
of books here.
My new novel is called Rage Is
Back, and it is a story about
the New York City graffiti
writers of the '80s making a
dramatic comeback in 2005, and
taking over every train in the
New York City subway system at
once, painting them all in
order to exact a long delayed
revenge against the former
transit cop who is now
running for mayor.
And it's a little different than
my previous book, Go The
Fuck To Sleep, although if
you're a fan of that book, I
would say that this book
contains far more curses.
This book took me much
longer to write.
Three years, 35 minutes.
Both, however, were
labors of love.
And some people kind of-- a lot
of the conversations I'm
having about the new book begin
with the previous book,
which is understandable,
because, like T Cooper said,
I'm the Go The Fuck
To Sleep guy.
Sometimes people know that I
wrote other novels before
this, and sometimes
they don't.
I'm always flattered when they
do, because I wrote, like, I
don't know, three or four
novels before this.
When this book came out-- when
Go The Fuck To Sleep came out,
there was a lot of hooplah, and
shit happened to me that I
never expected to happen,
and that I still
can't believe happened.
Like, I was on the
Today Show twice.
And I'm basically the type of
writer who definitively does
not get to go on the Today Show,
because I write literary
fiction that doesn't contain
vampires or, like, love
stories for the ages or
anything like that.
But, like, with this one, it
was just a little cute book
that I wrote kind
of as a joke.
But it turned out that every
parent in the world feels the
way that I did.
It's funny, because the book
barely got published.
I barely even attempted
to publish it.
I wrote it, I read it at dinner
parties for a couple of
months, and then I sent it to
my friend who runs a very
small independent publishing
house in Brooklyn, has a
couple of kids.
I knew they didn't sleep.
I thought he might think
it was funny.
And there was this strange
moment where we both thought
the book was really funny, and
yet neither of us was really
ready to pull the trigger
and publish it.
We thought we might just be
bad parents, you know?
And then even after he decided
that he would publish it, we
had all these conundrums,
all these problems.
We didn't know simple stuff,
like where the bookstore would
this book be stocked?
We were clear that the
children's section was
inappropriate, in that it
says fuck on the cover.
But we didn't, like--
was it humor?
Is it this?
And this was resolved one day
when Johnny, my publisher,
walked into his local
independent bookstore and
presented the book to them,
and asked them where they
would stock it.
And they read it, and they
laughed, and they were like,
oh, this is perfect.
This goes in the parenting
section.
And me and Johnny were like,
there's a parenting section?
Which confirms the earlier
thesis about us being shitty
parents, I guess.
But yeah, like, on the Today
Show, I went on a couple
times, and once they knew who
I was, and once they didn't.
And the first time I was on
there with Matt Lauer, right?
Real stand up guy.
Very, very nice.
There's a real art to
interviewing people,
especially in a fraught
situation like live national
television.
Everybody's nervous, it's real
early in the morning, you're
heavily caffeinated, and you're
in front of a plate
glass window, and all these
people are, like, behind it
holding up signs that they made
that morning at their
hotels or whatever.
I don't know what the hell
they're doing there.
But like, I don't know if
they're from the Kalamazoo,
Michigan Board of Tourism or
whatever, because they're
behind, they're like, aah!
Kalamazoo!
It's like, you came to New York
to stand here at 6:45 in
the morning with a sign
that says Kalamazoo?
Really?
That's your idea
of a vacation?
Anyway, so Matt Lauer has like
two minutes before you go live
on air to make you
feel comfortable.
And he's great at his job.
By the time I went on with Matt
Lauer, I felt like we
were old friends, and after the
interview, we were going
to go eat some pancakes or
hit some golf balls.
Whatever the fuck Matt Lauer
does for fun, you know?
And we get on, and the first
thing he says is, Adam, before
this book, you wrote
several novels.
You're an award winning
novelist.
And I was real grateful
for that.
And the interview was cool.
And then I came back two days
later to do the Today Show
again, with Kathie
Lee Gifford.
It's a very different
situation.
Everybody referred to this as
the 11:00 hour, which sounded
really ominous.
I didn't know what that means.
In retrospect, it means that
Kathie Lee Gifford starts
drinking at 10:00.
And like, again, two minutes
to make me feel comfortable
before we go on air.
The last thing Kathie Lee
Gifford says to me before the
cameras roll and we're live
to however many million
households is, your
daughter Vivian.
How old is she, that
little bitch?
I was like, really, Kathie
Lee Gifford?
I will punch you in your face
on live television.
Like, I know I wrote a book with
curse words in it, but
yo, for real, Kathie
Lee Gifford?
So I was like, totally
flustered
when the cameras rolled.
I didn't know what
was going on.
It was crazy.
So, sometimes weird
things happen.
And a lot of weird things
happened with this book.
Among other things, people
often got the mistaken
impression that I
am a parenting
expert or a sleep guru.
People also got the impression
that this was
a children's book.
Like, people were up in arms on
the interwebs talking about
how they would never read
this book to a child.
It seems to me that it would
take a startling unique blend
of literacy and illiteracy to
mistakenly read this book to a
child, in that it says
fuck on the cover.
Again, I'll come back to that.
One of the incidents that was,
to me, the funniest was, I was
asked to be a co-host
at a charity event.
A fundraiser for a Boston
children's hospital.
I'm from Boston, but the event
was in LA, because presumably,
people in LA have
a lot of money.
So the co-host--
my co-host at the event was
this guy, Doctor Richard
Ferber, who may be familiar
to some of
you if you have children.
Who has kids in this audience?
OK.
Richard Ferber-- that
ring a bell?
The Ferber Method?
Sleep training?
He's regarded by some
as a monster, and
by others as a hero.
He's a titan of the field.
His theory is basically
that you should let
your kid cry it out.
It's the opposite
of what we would
call attachment parenting.
Among those who find his work
controversial and monstrous is
my wife Victoria, who was
accompanying me to the event.
And I was seriously afraid that
she was going to, like,
throw a drink in his face or
something, because that theory
of letting your kid scream and
cry until they fall asleep,
and thus freeing yourself from
the type of situation you deal
with if you don't, she could
never really wrap her mind
around that.
So I was worried about that.
Doctor Ferber had requested
some slides from the book.
Some images from the book to
use in his presentation.
I was not giving
a presentation.
My job was to drink
and shake hands.
I'm a titan when it comes to
drinking and shaking hands.
I'm great at that.
And like, it was totally
inappropriate for him to give
a presentation, because these
were a bunch of decadent, rich
LA people who didn't need a 20
minute slide show about how to
put your kids to bed, because
they have nannies who do that.
So he's giving this long
presentation, and when he
finally gets around to the
images from the book, the one
that he shows is an
image of a father.
And this illustration is based
on me, because my Illustrator
Ricardo works from
photographs.
A guy who looks something
like me, sneaking out
of the kid's room.
The verse goes like this.
Bleary and dazed, I awaken to
find your eyes shut, so I keep
my fingers crossed tight as I
tiptoe away and pray that
you're fucking asleep.
And he put it on the screen.
He was like, this is what
you should never do.
I was like, really, Doc?
You just threw me
under the sleep
training bus, Dr. Ferber?
And it was kind of wild.
I was standing in the back,
imbibing, you know?
But the crazy part is that the
next morning, I get an email
from Dr. Ferber.
And the email-- we're staying
in the same hotel.
He could have just knocked
on my door.
And the email says, why didn't
you tell me that I know you?
I'm like, Dr. Ferber
has lost his mind.
And it turns out that I
went to summer camp--
before I got kicked out, which
is a separate story.
I used to get kicked out
of a lot of things.
Sunday school, summer camp.
I went to summer camp with
his son, Thad Ferber.
The unforgettably named
Thad Ferber.
And when you're like 13, your
friends from summer camp who
live two towns away, you see
them like, once during the
school year.
So when I was 13 in 1990, Thad
Ferber and I went to Tower
Records on Newbury
Street in Boston.
And I was a hip hop
kid, right?
I was a rapper, I was a DJ,
which is why I'm writing
novels about graffiti
these days.
And so we went up to the top
floor to buy some rap records,
and there was a big life size
cardboard cutout of MC Hammer
up there, because MC Hammer,
from Oakland,
was large in 1990.
But he wasn't exactly the
purest of products.
Those of us who were rap
purists had a real
problem with him.
We thought he was watering
down the music.
He was at the top of
the pop charts.
You may remember the large pants
he liked to dance in,
and subsequently the Kentucky
Fried Chicken ads he starred
in, followed by a long,
drawn out bankrupty.
So naturally, I ripped the
head off the cardboard MC
Hammer cutout and stuffed it in
my jacket, which was not an
act of theft as much
as decapitation.
And I attempted to exit the
store and was apprehended by
security, in classic fashion,
trying to go through the
revolving door, and they came
and put their foot and took me
and Thad Ferber, who was guilty
by association, down to
the dungeon beneath
Tower Records.
And there, they browbeat us and
told us that the cardboard
cutout cost like $8,000--
which I find dubious--
and he told me I was banned for
life from Tower Records,
and they would only release me
into the custody of the police
or my parents.
So this was not my
first rodeo.
I got in trouble quite a bit.
So I had a phone number
memorized that was a fake
number that just
rang and rang.
So I gave them that number as
my parents' number, and it
just rang and rang, and I was
like, I guess they're out.
Thad Ferber had never been to
the rodeo before, so he gave
them his parents' number.
And in short order, Dr. Richard
Ferber showed up and
took us both home.
And I had totally forgot
about this.
I had never connected Thad
Ferber to Richard Ferber, so
my mind was blown.
And it actually made me feel a
lot better about everything,
because clearly, Dr. Ferber is
not that great of a fucking
parent, in that he let his
son hang out with me.
So that was one of the richer
anecdotes from the Go The Fuck
To Sleep insanity.
Also good was the time that they
tried to ban the book in
New Zealand, of all
places, right?
New Zealand.
I think of New Zealanders,
Kiwis, as
being fairly free spirited.
But there's a group there--
and in fairness, the censorship
efforts never got anywhere.
But it was this group called
Family First New Zealand.
And the president of the
organization, who I think was
also probably the vice
president, the sergeant at
arms, the secretary,
you know--
put out this press release,
which I thought was great.
I have it framed in
my office now.
And it said, while this book may
be amusing and harmless in
the hands of normal, well
adjusted people, we are really
worried about its effects in
the hands of aggressive,
dysfunctional parents.
I was like, that's the rubric
for what we ban now?
What aggressive dysfunctional
people should
not have access to?
Do you also propose
to ban spoons?
That could be a problem in
the hands of aggressive,
dysfunctional people.
Luckily for us, the audiobook,
which was read in this country
by Samuel L Jackson, and also
Werner Herzog did a version
for us as well.
You should YouTube that one.
Also an adorable Filipino
grandmother, whose version
went viral on the interwebs.
That's probably my favorite.
In Australia and New Zealand,
the reader was this woman
named Noni Hazlehurst.
Anybody from that part
of the world in the
building right now?
Yeah?
You know who Noni
Hazlehurst is?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ADAM MANSBACH: Yeah, she
was on Playschool.
She's like Maria from Sesame
Street crossed with Meryl
Streep for that part
of the world.
She's like, a successful film
actor who also is a legendary
child's television presenter.
And when Family First New
Zealand came out with their
objections, Noni Hazlehurst
went on national TV and
basically told them to go fuck
themselves, and that was,
like, the end of it.
And that was an interesting
phenomenon here, too.
Whenever somebody came out of
the woodwork and objected to
the book in whatever way, the
grandmothers of America
basically stepped in to our
defense and shut down
everything.
And they had, like, the ultimate
moral authority.
And they turned out to be a
really hip and crass group of
people, and I'm very
grateful to them.
So yeah.
I ended up talking nonstop
about this book for like,
eight months, eight hours
a day, crazy amounts of
interviews and stuff.
And it's nice to have
a new novel out.
And there is a connection, I
think, between the two books,
in the sense that what I'm
interested in exploring in my
work is sort of paradox
and human complexity.
I think that's where narrative
and conflict come from.
That's where good fiction
comes from.
And that can be a very simple
paradox, like the paradox of
loving your kid to death, but
also being willing to do
anything in the world to get out
of that kid's room after
an hour and a half of trying to
put that little creatures
to bed, or it can be kind of
larger societal paradoxes.
In this book, I'm dealing with
the world of graffiti.
Subway graffiti as it originated
as a movement in
New York City in the
'70s and '80s.
It was controversial then,
it remains so now.
But for me, the lives of
graffiti writers are
fascinating, because
they embody so many
tensions and paradoxes.
They tend to be the eccentrics,
the mad geniuses,
the theorists of hip hop.
And I've enjoyed getting to
know them over the past 25
years of my life.
And the paradoxes that they have
to deal with are sort of
the tension between fame
and anonymity.
These guys are pursuing fame
in a brilliant and original
fashion, right?
The New York City subway trains
became their canvases.
These were kids who were largely
disenfranchised,
coming out of marginal living
conditions in the Bronx and
Brooklyn, at a time when New
York City was bankrupt--
at a time when art and music
programs had all but been
destroyed in that city--
at a time when--
this is New York circa Ford
to New York drop dead.
Jimmy Carter driving through the
Bronx, and getting out of
his car, and frowning and
getting back in and
disappearing.
These kids figured out how to
make the subway trains of New
York their personal canvases.
They circulated through the
city, and were seen by
millions of people a day.
The city of New York spent $300
million between 1972 and
1990 trying to win this
war against a bunch of
15-year-olds.
Those 15-year-olds outsmarted
them at every turn.
And to me, there's always been
something epic and heroic
about graffiti in
a certain sense.
So there's that tension between
art and vandalism.
Most graffiti writers view
their work as both, and
they're not trying to privilege
one over the other.
They see it as equally valuable
for both those reasons.
Fame and anonymity, art and
vandalism, beautifying and
destroying a city.
Even today, the war on graffiti,
although it's been
successful in removing graffiti
from the subway
trains, rages on.
The same space that once
featured these illegal but
often very beautiful murals done
by the teenagers of New
York City, you can now buy
advertising space on these
trains-- on the outsides
of these trains.
For $50,000 a month, you can buy
strips of advertising that
will run on the exteriors
of subway trains.
So in this war over public
space, which was a coded war,
which was largely a
war against young
underprivileged kids--
kids of color, largely--
in New York City--
now, public space can be yours
if you can pay for it.
And yet, the city of New York is
still so violently opposed
to graffiti--
even the aesthetic
of graffiti--
that the one thing you can't
advertise on the outside of
the train--
you can't use anything
that looks--
"looks" like graffiti.
So you can put a naked
woman in a dog
collar advertising vodka.
That's cool with CBS outdoor,
which administers these ads on
behalf of the MTA
and the city.
You can put a placard on a bus
that is widely regarded as
hate speech against
Palestinians.
That got through.
But when I tried to advertise
this book--
and to be fair, I knew they
were going to say no.
I didn't have $50,000 to spend
on no damn train--
they rejected the advertising,
because
it looked like graffiti.
And to me, this is where the
sort of intellectual
bankruptcy of the policy becomes
clear, because the MTA
and the City of New York define
graffiti as vandalism.
They define it as the defacement
of property through
a list of means.
A litany of ways.
What I'm proposing to do on this
train is not vandalism.
It's advertising.
And yet, the aesthetic is
being-- so it's the
criminalization now not of an
action, but of an aesthetic.
So to tell me that I can't put
graffiti style letters on the
train, there's no real legal or
intellectual basis for it.
A graffiti style letter, in this
context, is kind of like
a robbery style purchase.
It doesn't actually
make sense.
But this war was never
about aesthetics.
It was about public space and
who had access to it.
So what I try to do in the book,
which I don't have time
to read from, unfortunately,
is deal with the return of
these writers from the '70s
and '80s who have been
marginalized, who have
disappeared because the thing
they invented they have now
paradoxically outlived.
Graffiti has become a worldwide
phenomenon, but it
no longer exists in the vibrant,
original form that it
once did in their own city.
And the story is told by the
son of two famous writers.
He's an 18-year-old
kid named Dondi.
He's recently been kicked out
of his prestigious Manhattan
prep school for selling
marijuana--
a prep school he refers to
throughout the book only as
Whoop Dee Woo, Ivy League,
We's A Comin' Academy.
And through the return of his
father, who's been on the lam
for 16 years, and the
reassemblage of his father's
shattered graffiti crew, and
some minor incidents of time
travel and some possible demons
who may or may not live
deep within the bowels of
the tunnel system--
New York's tunnel system goes 18
levels deep in some places,
so there are a lot of
unused tunnels.
There are people living in
those tunnels-- the mole
people, they're sometimes
known as-- they make an
appearance in here as well.
This elaborate caper comes
together to attempt to paint
every train at once, thus
affecting either a total
shutdown of the MTA, which would
wreak havoc on New York,
or the running, once again, of
painted trains, which is
intended to bring down this
figure who's historically the
enemy of these graffiti
writers.
It's a book I had a lot of fun
writing, and I'll leave it at
that, because I think we need
time for some Q and A, and
I've been running
my mouth enough.
So thank you Google, Googlers,
for having us today.
We appreciate it.
And if you want to buy
some books, we
definitely will sign.
And even if you don't, the
discount that you get is
actually better than mine.
So if you buy some books, I'm
happy to buy them from you at
a slight markup.
So we can talk about that.
Off camera.
You wanna come back up here?
AUDIENCE: Thank you, Adam
and T, for speaking.
Adam, I have a question
for you.
You said that after you wrote
your book, Go The Fuck To
Sleep, people were coming to you
as some parenting expert.
And you currently have
a radio show on KPFA
called Father Figures.
ADAM MANSBACH: Yes.
I'm still pretending to
be a parenting expert.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering, did
that show come out of the
book, or were you
doing it before?
And I was wondering if you could
just talk about your
role as sort of a theorist
on fatherhood today.
ADAM MANSBACH: The show came
about after the book.
I was living in Philadelphia
when the book was published.
I had a temporary teaching
residency at Rutgers
University in Camden.
Lovely Camden, New Jersey.
When I moved back to the Bay,
my good friend Wayland
Southern, who has been a KPFA
host on a show called Hard
Knock Radio that's been an
institution in the Bay since
1996, he had also recently
had a daughter.
And both of us were interested
in exploring some of the
nuances of parenthood, and
telling some of the stories
that go untold.
I mean, the reason Go The Fuck
To Sleep was successful is
because there's a huge culture
of silence about some of the
more difficult or complicated
aspects of parenting.
And we felt like we had a huge
cadre of friends who had
recently had kids, and that a
new generation of fathers
needed an outlet to kind
of tell their stories.
So what we do on the show--
it's a talk show, and we talk
to mothers and fathers.
Largely, we bring on people
that we enjoy
and think are brilliant.
We bring on a lot of artists,
musicians, writers, and the
topic is sometimes parenthood.
Often we get very far afield
from that, and talk about what
people are actually doing
with their work.
But the common denominator is
parenthood, and a desire to
kind of plumb its mysteries
a little deeper.
So we've been on the
air about a year.
It's 11:00 to 12:00 Saturdays
on KPFN, and also
streaming on the web.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ADAM MANSBACH: Yeah.
I also was able to sell a sitcom
to CBS about a dude who
publishes a fake children's
book, and then has to pose as
a parenting expert in order to
keep riding the gravy train.
Jerry O'Connell was going
to star in it
as a me-esque jackass.
It didn't get picked up, so
you're not missing it or
anything, but we did write
a pilot, which was a fun
experience.
AUDIENCE: And I have a follow-up
question for T. T, I
was wondering if you could talk
a little bit about what
your experience was like
publishing your latest book
with McSweeney's, because
McSweeney's is known for
having some kind of off
the wall productions.
And it looks like you've done
some multimedia with the video
that you showed at the beginning
with the CD.
And I was wondering if you could
kind of talk more about
the sort of mixed media format
for your latest book.
T COOPER: They're just really
great to work with.
I'm really honored that I got
to, because, you know, if you
think it, they'll do it.
You have some experience
there too.
I think that they would've been
fine with me moving into
the 15th level under the subways
and being a mole
people with this book.
Anything from there
to the Today Show.
But it's weird, because Matt
Lauer didn't call me.
But anyway, I told them,
like, music is--
I have a lot of musical friends,
and a lot of access
to artists.
If you check out the CD, there's
some really diverse,
interesting people.
And once I started putting that
together, it just kind of
was natural to have events
that were music related.
So this is actually the first
time, or maybe the second
event that I haven't had live
music along with me.
And again, anything that takes
the focus off me, thumbs up.
So I just work with them, and
they were willing to think
creatively about venues,
and I don't know.
I was really lucky.
And the book also-- there's
artwork throughout.
Pretty much every chapter starts
with some piece of
artwork, either my own or
artists, or there's charts and
graphs and photographs and
found stuff and stuff.
So they understand that
storytelling is not square.
Even though they do put out
books, interestingly, they're
not always square.
But I mean, they get that it's
kind of a bigger piece that
you're putting together, and
there's so many different ways
to tell stories.
So they just let me
tell it however.
They didn't impose an ending.
They didn't say make it happy,
make it tragic and then happy,
which you do hear a lot.
So it was great.
Thanks for asking.
AUDIENCE: Could you talk a bit
about Angry Black White Boy,
if I have the name right?
ADAM MANSBACH: You do, yeah.
Angry Black White Boy is a
novel that I published in
2005, and it was kind of my
attempt to remix the American
race novel for the hip
hop generation.
As I said earlier, as that MC
Hammer anecdote perhaps
illustrated, I've been involved
and invested in hip
hop for a long time.
And at the time that I got into
it in the late '80s, it
was really one of the only sites
in American life where
whiteness was made subjective--
where as a white
person, you had to really think
critically about race
and privilege.
So Angry Black White
Boy is a satire.
It's the story of an Afrocentric
white kid named
Macon Detornay who is kind of
politicized by the music he
grows up listening to-- the era
of Public Enemy and X Clan
and Boogie Down Productions--
and develops a rather profound
or extreme critique of white
privilege in America, and ends
up acting on that as a New
York City cab driver.
He begins robbing other white
people who get in his cab,
which leads to a manhunt for
the presumably black cab
driver who's sticking up
all these white people.
He ends up becoming kind of an
infamous celebrity once he's
apprehended, and uses his new
found platform to call for a
national day of apology, based
on a rhetorical statement in
Malcolm X's autobiography.
Malcolm says, the nature of
racism in this country is so
pernicious, so persistent, so
unavoidable, and benefits
white people every day of their
lives, that they should
really be walking up to black
folks on the street and
apologizing.
Now, this is a rhetorical
statement in Malcolm's book.
Macon is like, we're going to
do this shit on Friday.
So people from all over the
country go to New York to
participate in this well
intentioned and ill considered
and ultimately disastrous day of
apology, and things kind of
take off from there.
MATT WERNER: I would like to
thank Adam and T Cooper for
coming to Google.